el anuncio llegó por sorpresa a la sede
de California Bob iger regresa a Walt
Disney Company como director ejecutivo
menos de un año después de haberse
retirado quien fue responsable de las
adquisiciones de Pixar Marvel o Twenty
First Century Fox vuelve a petición de
los dirigentes del grupo que confían en
él para revertir la mala tendencia
económica de la compañía
la junta concluyó que dado que Disney
entra en un período cada vez más
complejo de transformación de la
industria Bob aiger cuenta con una
situación única para dirigir la compañía
en este periodo crucial de este modo Bob
Iker pone fin a su breve jubilación tras
15 años al frente de Disney en 2020 dejó
el cargo pero permaneció en la empresa
hasta finales de 2021 para facilitar la
transición a su sucesor que ya renunció
durante su corta dirección chapex se
enfrentó al cierre de los parques debido
a la pandemia a las críticas por tardar
en defender los derechos lgbt y q más en
Florida y sobre todo los malos
resultados económicos Bob iger rehereda
ahora una situación difícil las acciones
de Disney cayeron un 40% en lo que va de
2022 en parte por los malos resultados
del servicio de streaming Disney Plus
que ya ha generado pérdidas de 1.500
millones de dólares en el último
trimestre a los 71 años de edad hay que
regresa por un periodo de 24 meses tras
el cual elegirá a su próximo